One misconception
of meditation is
that if you're meditating
your mind will be blank.
You can't make your mind blank.
And if you try, you're
just going to wind up
with a gigantic headache.
[LAUGHS]
In a way, when
we're on autopilot,
we're sleepwalking
through our lives.
Mindfulness is traditionally
a form of meditation.
It's the awareness that
arises from paying attention
on purpose in the present
moment and nonjudgmentally.
If you're breathing, this
class could be for you.
I've been committed
to mindfulness
for well over 50 years.
It's a way in which you
could take care of your body,
take care of your mind.
And that's what this
is really about.
The entire thrust
of this MasterClass
is not about attaining.
It's about recognizing
you're already whole.
When you set about bringing
mindfulness into your life,
the best coping strategy
is to recognize stress
and how to minimize
our reactivity
to those stressors, no
matter how stressful,
no matter how painful.
I could ground myself
in the present moment.
Stop, remember,
drop.
We can cultivate mindfulness
in an array of different ways.
And the beauty of
meditation is some forms
will resonate with some people.
And other forms will resonate
differently with other people.
I do not consider this
to be a master class.
This is not about mastery.
I'm not the curriculum.
You're the curriculum.
This is an invitation to
befriend yourself and sign up
for the adventure of a lifetime.
This is Jon Kabat-Zinn, and
this is my non-MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]